on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
tonight
a little girl she couldn't help but my
teachers I feel alive but they're shot
child's heartbreaking 9-1-1 call exposes
shocking police cowardice in the Uvalde
school massacre
also tonight broken and out of control
the British government admits there's a
migrant crisis but where are their ideas
for fixing it
plus it's protest intensified of the
World Cup and Qatar is it time for
whining sports stars to either shut up
or pull out
[Music]
live from London this is Piers Morgan
uncensored good evening Fernando and
welcome to Piers Morgan unsensitive when
a country appears to lose control of its
borders as we're seeing in Joe Biden's
United States for example people feel
unsafe and they feel resentful so as
Britain lost control as our own Home
Secretary says well look at some facts
40 000 people across English Channel and
small boats this year it's already a
record many of them are trafficked here
by criminal gangs you don't care if they
live or drown there's a backlog of a
hundred thousand Asylum cases a major
Migrant Center is four times its
capacity with third world conditions and
outbreaks of diphtheria another one was
attacked with a petrol bomb this doesn't
look like control to me in fact quite
the opposite it's fast becoming the
first crisis of what's been a
reassuringly crisis-free start otherwise
so as you see the next Premiership
here's what secure starmer said it prime
minister's questions today
if the Asylum system is broken and his
lot have been in power for 12 years how
how can it be anyone
anyone theirs
well he's right they told us very
clearly when we get brexit done we can
control our borders but we haven't the
numbers are going up not down and we
quite clearly do not have control but
what the Prime Minister said in response
sums up the abject mess that we're now
in
border control is a serious complex
issue but not only does the party
opposite not have a plan they have
opposed every single measure we have
taken to solve the problem you can't
attack a plan if you don't have a plan
well he's right isn't it it's very easy
to throw rocks the stupid ideas but what
is Labor's solution I'm yet to hear a
good one Royal Navy patrols have failed
throwing money the French and leaving it
with them has also failed ludicrously
threatening to fly everyone to Rwanda so
far has cost 140 million pounds and
resulted in precisely zero deportations
has also failed and the worst thing of
all this is the woman currently in
charge of fixing it
the British people deserve to know which
party is serious about stopping The
Invasion on our southern coast
invasion
it's not Invasion an invasion is what
Vladimir Putin is doing in Ukraine with
tanks are Rockets sort of Brahman knew
exactly what she was doing defecting
attention from her own scandals and
incompetence what Britain faces is the
crisis of his own making and a crisis of
talentless Leaders with no clue what to
do about it sacking leaky Sue might be a
good place to start but let's be also
clear about another thing Britain needs
immigrants so the backbone of so much of
this country the NHS hospitality
You Name It We rely a lot on immigrants
in this country they pay vast fees to
study in our world-class universities
they service in restaurants bars shops
they toil in our Fields these people
work hard often in jobs nobody else
wants to do and they pay taxes we need
more legal immigration you ask anybody
who works in these industries we need
more but we also need to control illegal
immigration and these two things can go
hand in hand
well joining me now is the chair of Brit
PC UK and former politician Henry Bolton
a broadcaster Jenny cleeman well welcome
to both of you
um Henry Bolton when swella bravaman
uses a phrase like invasion
she does it to Rally the rights uh to
Rally people who think we are literally
being invaded by illegal immigrants
that's not true we're not being invaded
by illegal immigrants they're not
invading us these are in many cases
desperate people coming because they
have nowhere else to be they've been
maybe in war-torn countries not all
summer gaming the system we know that
but to describe them as an invasion is
such inflammatory stupid rhetoric it
appears I'm going to partly agree with
you and partly disagree
um we talk about Pitch invasions are we
saying that that's inflammatory the
answer is no and you're comparing
refugees and Asylum Seekers to football
Hooligans I I think actually I think
actually appears you're comparing the
language that you'd use regarding an
invasion of a football pitch with
compare with what the Home Secretary has
said no you've literally just compared
refugees and Asylum Seekers to football
Hooligans
that again is what I call needlessly
inflammatory yes you've asked me a
question and you've answered it because
you're now making an accusation about
something that's not true what are they
saying what I'm saying is that you that
there is a hypocrisy amongst people in
the media who are saying Suella bravaman
is wrong to call this an invasion when
actually one of the accepted definitions
of invasion for example you can have an
invasion of flying ants you can never
sorry have a look at the dictionary
sorry so you're now comparing refugees
and Asylum bottom line here football
Hooligans and flying apps do not
understand him
understand that the majority of people
as you said in your introduction are
highly concerned about this yes and the
situation is that what we've got in the
media is people focusing on whether the
Home Secretary called it an invasion or
whether or not the instead of whether
the government's got a plan to solve it
and what I agree with you on is that the
government doesn't have a plan it hasn't
had a plan for for years and in this
this situation
literally that's what we should all be
focusing literally it's the government
development but the reason we're
focusing on the use of language is
precisely for what you've just done
you've just compared Asylum Seekers and
refugees
are flying and yes 42 and that is
incredibly interesting here's 42 of the
people who've come across the channel
since May this year are albanians 95 of
which are young men between age ages 18
and 30 70 of albanians in the UK do not
come from Albania did you know that I do
because I was a un governor in Kosovo I
was advised to the albrane Albanian
prime minister and I led the UK's
efforts in the Republic of Macedonia
next door to disrupt transnational
they're also perfectly entitled Henry
they're perfectly entitled to try and
come into this country then they should
be processed and they should be
processed there is an asylum no if they
qualify for them and they are at the
moment but they are not for example in
Germany or France because Germany and
France have said no because Germany and
France recognize that Albania is a safe
country and the reality is that we've
got an issue here which comes together
and I'm not I've got Albanian friends I
worked in it don't try that
don't come out with me you're really
being quite aggressive you're trying to
imagine because the language the
language is Braverman life no my
language they're all a bunches invading
us they're a bunch of flying ants my
knots
peers would you please let me get a word
in yes thank you I said that I feel
that's a hypocrisy between the media who
you perfectly happy using the word
invasion in relation to football fans
and
and you are saying that problem is not
right you'll call it a football Invasion
but you I'm sorry let me explain
ridiculous teachers a thousand people
all right
I think here's the problem the Casual
use of this kind of language and analogy
it's a casual period part of the problem
is that when you compare genuine
refugees which many of them will be
people seeking Asylum many coming from
countries which by the way have been
warts on because we started a war there
not in Albania oh my God no but we have
in places like Iraq right now right 12
000
this is part of the problem if you
demonize all these people that to me
doesn't help anybody the point is you
are deliberately either setting people
up as your enemy that invades you or
you're dehumanizing them which I'm doing
ants or or cockroaches or whatever it is
all she's got is rhetoric can you name a
single thing that she's done in all the
time that she has been in the cabinet
she has nothing she has no ideas she has
no plans she just has language where she
talks about her dream of sending people
to Rwanda she talks about tofu eating
work karate that's all she's got culture
wars she uses this language to deflect
from the fact that she doesn't have a
plan and the problem is not the invasion
of migrants the problem is the backlog
and the backlog is caused by problems at
the home office with processing people
yes Henry you would agree with I would
agree and yes 14 governments to solve
problems of nearly this scale no I'm
successful I agree and my point I would
totally agree there is no plan process
is wrong the law is wrong that there are
these knee-jerk reactions coming out of
the home office and the government such
as you're quite quite right I totally
agree with you regarding the ridiculous
idea of sending them to Rwanda this is
all ridiculous stuff the fact is that
there is no cohesive strategy and that
without that strategy there is not going
to be a proper plan cross-government at
the very least but the very least the
very least we should be doing is
treating these people with a basic
dignity and respect I agree they're
prepared to risk their lives which many
of them do and many have lost their
lives in the process of coming over the
channel in dinghies because vile
traffickers have screwed them for
however much money it may be the least
we can do as a supposedly civilized
Humane country is has actually treat
them with some form of dignity can we
not forget that there was a terrorist
attack on an asylum Center on Sunday and
we know that this kind of language
humanizing language treating these
people as Invaders people who are coming
to take over our country people who are
insects is the sort of thing that
enables terrorists to commit these
terrible attracts Henry let me ask you
something Henry Henry Bolton you were
very exercised about the just stop oil
activists and you tweeted this arrest
charged for criminal damage prosecute
sentenced to whatever community service
hours are required to clean it and find
for whatever it costs jail for six
months very strong unequivocal this is
how we deal with them right I'm a former
police officer as well and I have
arrested people for lesser criminal
damage than that yeah they have been
they've the crown prosecution service
have made the decision to charge they've
gone to court and they've been sent to
jail and given community service and
what was your reaction went so what was
your reaction through a petrol bomb and
a Dover migrants I'm appalled really yes
let me remind you what you're actually
doing no bang on Twitter hang on foreign
bombs at the Dover Migrant Center which
is on fire then took their own life the
shocking news shows the level of
frustration it does it's shocking news
because
it's very shocking you're not you think
it's not shocking and you think that
this was an absolute racist lunity fine
waging a terror campaign that's innocent
that's migrants migrants there is
something that I think all three of us
can you see more you see more appalled
and more Draconian about a bunch of
people spring paint on buildings now
you've been you are about a bloke trying
to murder people now you're being
ridiculous
that's literally your tweets within the
space of two days that is the contact
context of what we I think all three can
agree on is that the government doesn't
have a properly cohesive and thought
through plan for this yes
you're going to see these problems it's
not justifying them fine it feels like a
joke it doesn't it doesn't unfortunately
you put it down to it shows how
frustrated people are no
murderous Maniacs who are racists who
want to kill migrants of course that's
what that showed peers if you look at my
career I've spent most of it fighting
people like that you can understand
people being confused you can understand
that you see more angry
that's what led to them doing what they
did you said lock them up I agree
unfortunately you can't lock that man up
can you right what I am saying what I'm
trying to illustrate here is that there
is a need to put pressure on the
government to come up with a cohesive
plan and you cannot deny all right if
there is severe frustration look I think
most sensible people can agree it is
ridiculous these numbers rocketing of
people coming over illegally on dinghies
and it have to be dealt with and nothing
so far as word but I think we can also
agree that this country needs a good
level of legal immigration of people who
will enhance our country and right now
if you speak to anybody in many
Industries like Hospitality for example
it's on NHS they are crying out for
people absolutely my sister runs a
restaurant she is trying to recruit for
from overseas because she cannot she
cannot recruit absolutely it's a
complete catastrophe and if this is what
taking back control is I don't know what
being out of control is it is a complete
disaster this is a problem of our own
making we could have done a lot better
to control our borders if for example we
hadn't been deliberately alienating but
the French by saying we didn't know
whether or not they were our friends or
are or our enemies there is so much more
that we could have done this is uh
entirely a failure of 12 Years of
conservative government we've had think
about it we've had the ridiculous the
Hostile environments policy we had the
real round of policy we had the whole
window
it's all been a disaster and what we
need is proper leadership to actually
sort the two problems out one how do we
stop people risking their lives and
possibly dying being trafficked over the
channel and secondly how do we have a
better system of Asylum and refugees
which actually deals with these
applications quickly you work out who
should be here and who should because we
actually lag quite far behind many
European countries on how many we taking
anyway good competent Home Secretary to
do that though one that is driven by
practice and peers I think that's what
the conversation that really we should
be having and all of us putting pressure
on the government to respond I agree but
Henry I'm going to end by how I started
in saying that the use of language is
very important you do not get anywhere
in this debate by demonizing people by
using sub-human language about them and
for my point I would like to say that I
agree with you I I do not and have not
equated however you'd like to put it
however you'd like to present it I have
not equated the refugees and the Asylum
Seekers and migrants okay let me explain
President Putin okay or let me explain
let me explain exactly they are simply
let me explain large numbers
exactly that's got to be done let me
explain exactly how you did compare them
one more time because you said the use
of the word Invasion about refugees and
Asylum Seekers was justified because we
use about football Hooligans and flying
out I said it was exactly I'm afraid and
if you lose an analogy I also posted the
Oxford dictionary definition of what
invasion is and in that sense it's
difficult
it's only difficult if actually you look
at them as less than humans Jenny uh
Henry Bolton thank you very much indeed
still to come 18 days before uh the
World Cup starts from Qatar is it time
for the footballers to stop protesting
and focus on football uh but next drop
in your details about how it is in one
of America's worst school gun tragedies
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
welcome back to Facebook on censored
five months ago a lone gunman entered
Rob Elementary School in Uvalde Texas
altering two teachers and 19 children it
was the worst school shooting since
Sandy Hook a decade ago now shocking
audio of 9-1-1 calls with a 10 year old
girl trapped inside has emerged which
shows the police waited more than 40
minutes before taking action
this is how that Dreadful day unfolded
11 30 a.m CCTV footage shows the shooter
entering the school
moments later you can hear him firing on
my teachers and children inside
ten-year-old Chloe Torres is one of the
children trapped here are some of the
heartbreaking new 9-1-1 calls that have
just emerged that she made at the time
[Music]
um
yes
what's your name
please there's a lot of dead bodies
my dad taught me when I was a little
girl
they're inside of the building okay
stay inside the building you just need
to stay quiet
well Chloe survived and her parents gave
permission for those audio tapes to be
released to highlight The Unbelievable
failure by literally hundreds of armed
police who were waiting outside and what
were these officers doing when she made
that last call waiting in the corridors
they were standing there
you didn't do anything for another 40
minutes they didn't do anything after a
10 year old girl makes that call
it's really truly unconscionable well
eventually they finally entered the
classroom to tackle the shooter like I
say 40 minutes after that call from
Chloe
but by then of course
the real damage had been done well
joining me now is former Washington
homicide detective Ted Williams and
former FBI assistant director Chris
Decker who joins me from Carolina well
welcome to both of you Ted Williams
I gotta say I've I've always been
supportive of the police generally I
believe there are false for good in
America and UK and in most countries
when you look at what happened here and
when you listen to that heart-rending
series of of tapes on this poor little
girl I have a 10 year old daughter
myself so it particularly resonated I
just cannot understand
why given how many armed police was
literally Standing Outside they didn't
just rush inside and deal with this
situation can you
Pierce I don't think any of us can
understand and when we listen to this
child pleading for help and you have
grown men and women Law Enforcement
Officers with guns and armed would not
go into that classroom for 40 minutes or
I can tell you these uh Law Enforcement
Officers does do not represent the best
of law enforcement the best of law
enforcement would have gone in that
classroom right away to try to save as
many lives as possible these cowards
were more interested in saving their own
lives and their own skin than helping
those children 19 19 children and two of
their teachers died and you have a child
in that classroom crying out telling law
enforcement what the hell is going on in
there that they're dead kids and for 40
minutes they stood around twiddling
their storms it is just so embarrassing
and unacceptable to good Law Enforcement
Officers like I completely agree I mean
Christopher is there any anything you
could say to try and defend what
happened that day in terms of the law
enforcement conduct
no I mean first of all this was you
mentioned the word failure this was a
failure of preparation it was a failure
of leadership it was a failure of
execution it was a failure of training
these these officers act like they'd
never been through this before even in a
drill
there there is no I can't offer up any
mitigation other than to say that there
may be officers in there that felt they
were following orders but as I as I
studied this incident and I've studied
Parkland and I've studied Columbine the
Golden Rule as Detective Williams points
out is you go to the sound of gunfire
there's no more of this mustering up on
the perimeter getting Shields getting
the perfect situation and then going in
you go to the sound of the gunfire until
that gunfire stops and you neutralize
that threat this is when this is when
the rubber meets the road for law
enforcement this is what you signed up
to do and if you're not up to that you
need to find another profession I don't
want to be too hard you know you don't
want to judge these officers harshly
other than the one mitigation I can say
is that there were there were people on
the scene that seemed to be wanting to
to be the The Incident Commander if you
will and issuing some orders to stay
back now that you know that police chief
the of the school district now backs up
and says no I wasn't in charge well then
he should have been in charge he should
have taken charge and done exactly what
Detective Williams has said you go in
there and you confront the shooter and
save lives that's that's long I mean you
say we shouldn't talk about them or
judge them harshly I'd say I do want to
judge them harshly I wanted to judge
them harshly at the time and my anger
has only increased since I heard these
tapes this morning I literally couldn't
believe what I was hearing a 10 year old
girl calmly detailing exactly what is
happening explaining there are lots of
dead people inside and you have 400
armed law enforcement standing around
one of them we saw earlier at the start
of all this a few months ago was
actually washing his hands with hand
sanitizer children were being murdered
so I'm afraid I do judge them harshly in
fact I wrote a column for the New York
Post at the time saying I think they
should all be fired I mean Ted Williams
I I if they can't go in
to save children being blown to Pieces
by a maniac with guns what are they
doing as police officers why should they
keep their jobs
base
they shouldn't keep their jobs they
should all be fired they should all find
some kind of other employment than law
enforcement Mr Becker is right you Serve
and Protect your community and you have
children children dying you know they're
dying you know that their children in
there that have been murdered by this
bottom feeder and yet you stand around
and try to say that there is nobody in
command somebody could have taken Choice
the fact that there isn't there is no
excuse you cannot defend the
indefensible in this manner and as a
result of that they should all be fired
they shouldn't have anything to do with
law enforcement they are an
embarrassment to the good men and women
who serve in law enforcement all over
this country who would it immediately
immediately gone in there to try to save
lives well I'm you know I would liken it
I would liken it uh Chris Wecker to the
scenes on 9 11. when all those
firefighters it ran to what many of them
must have thought might be certain death
into the Twin Towers and lost their
lives they didn't hesitate for one
moment to do their Duty and do their
jobs and they were all heroes none of
this lot of Heroes are the complete
opposite of Heroes they're anti-heroes
they're people who when they were
finally tested with the biggest test of
their careers they utterly betrayed
those children and the teachers and the
families of those of those kids
no no question about it you know again
those in law enforcement know the rule
they they know the the procedures these
days this is 2022. we've learned from a
lot of these other mass shootings one
there's a preparation aspect to this
that falls on the law enforcement as
well but the execution aspect of it is
is clear-cut you go that's all there is
to it and I get I get a little bit upset
when I see these press conferences where
after a mass shooting law enforcement is
standing up there patting themselves on
the back when you know we that's not the
focus and that's not the purpose and
this lot did anything afterwards
they were lying right I mean they
eventually spun a pack of Lies
praising themselves for the heroism in
dealing with this shooter it's only
later thanks to some very good reporting
that we discovered the truth and these
tapes today they they're not just
heartbreaking they are they are shameful
they shame American law enforcement
cheers
what was more shameful was that what I
Define as the cover-up they lied they
lied on a teacher said that she left her
door open or the governor says that he
had been uh given false information uh
but guess what the governor hasn't taken
any action against anybody the uh the
chief of all of the Texas Rangers said
that if any of his people were involved
that he would be leaving he hasn't left
or nobody has taken responsibility or
accountability for the death of 19 on
students and two of their teachers no I
completely agree Ted Williams uh thank
you very much indeed for joining me and
Chris Wecker it's it's honestly it's
enraging it's an enraging story it was
enraging when it first happened it's got
more enraging over the months the more
we've learned about this sickening
cowardice uh but I appreciate you both
joining me thank you very much
will still come with the Guitar World
cut nearly upon us is it time for
everyone to stop protesting particularly
the players and either pull out of the
tournament or shut up and get on with
the football or debate that next
and how do you pronounce Adele's name
even she seem to know but that might be
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to Petersburg my dazzling
pack this evening is Kevin McGuire from
Daily Mirror and the times this legal
sketchwriter Quentin let's welcome Dad
to both of you a dazzling Duo uh I just
want to start by congratulating my
eldest son Spencer who just texted me to
say he's been playing football tonight
they won 11-7 and he scored nine goals
as he puts it Gareth Southgate where are
you uh quite right well please son
um gentlemen before we get into what
we're going to talk about
that debate there about what happened at
Uvalde we thank God don't have to put up
with this kind of endless cycle of mass
shootings and when we had one very
similar to this at dunblane we changed
our gun laws irrevocably but when you
see what happened there all I could
think about was when I was in America
trying to challenge the gun law
situation and getting nowhere I always
remember the NRA would pop up and they'd
say if only you had good guys with guns
at schools none of this would happen
they'd shoot the shooters the 400
supposedly good guys were guns and they
let these kids die it's the timidity of
protocol wasn't there yes but also moral
cowardice well yes but which is all that
that was all part of it's it's too much
part of it being the set procedures and
not being adaptable enough it was
extraordinary of I mean Kevin if any of
us were in that situation anyone and you
had a weapon and you knew there was
someone in a classroom killing children
I think we'd all go absolutely you would
want when you'd feel ashamed if you
didn't and someone said that you can't
because a protocol I think stuff your
protocol when they were actually holding
parents back outside the school it was
almost as if there were too many armed
police officers and no one was taking
control of the leadership the former
detective who was speaking yes very
powerful I thought I thought I thought
he was fantastic now whether you suck
them all or you retrain them if you can
and change how you operate I would I
would possibly disagree with him over
there because he was Hardline just sack
him but he was a type who would say
right you've just you've got to address
it you've got somebody someone to say
get in there lying like they're bleeding
as we now know this young girl had the
courage and presence of mind to phone
them and tell them exactly what was
happening if Joe Biden has any sense
he'll get her into the White House he
should yeah but try and affect some
change but the National Rifles you know
it's a visit and just to apologize for
the but your opponent National Rifle
Association facilitate the death of more
Americans and terrorists have ever
killed yeah I think that's true
um Quentin let's talk about quickly
Rishi sunag you wrote an interesting
column I just read before I came in
today most unusual you're scared
but you're writing an interesting
comments
I said there was a real a constant
difference after pmqs today between what
it felt like in the room yes and what
actually then you would watch back on
television and that he was much more
impressive as a television operator that
perhaps it seemed in the theater this
was to do with the quality of his voice
it doesn't cut through uh the the
terrible noise in the Commons chamber
and I sit up in the gallery almost
opposite him I find it really hard to
hear him today right
um because I was watching it live on TV
and I thought he handled himself very
well in fact if I was Kia stammer I
think I'd be getting a bit Twitchy about
Rishi for two reasons one they've got
two years they can wait until the
election as we know from the last three
months it's a very long time in politics
and should there be a recession but then
we start to come out of it and Rishi
sunlight can position himself as the guy
that got the ship back on track that's
not a bad election but more importantly
Kevin he was on the rack he's not a
buffoon right he's not a half wit he's
not someone who doesn't look like he's
obviously talking about he just seems a
pretty competent guy who's trying to go
about sorting stuff out but he's
certainly better than the last one uh
the last three I'd say at least
certainly uh certainly the last one in
terms of trust John May uh Johnson had a
big electoral appeal he did he did but I
don't think he had the substance well I
was trying to say about soon act today
was it worked his voice works better
yeah for a TV uh for the microphones
than it does in in this sort of the raw
no I get that of the comments if he
slightly disappears as a labor man but
what do you think about Rishi sooner oh
I think it's more credible than I I
agrees three three predecessors is
certainly more he's an adult doesn't
know that and again a grown-ups he had
to be treated differently but he was on
the back foot on migration starmer went
on an area that the Tories are
traditionally strong on and scored a lot
of points who's been in power for for 12
years it's a good point but I don't see
any real answers from labor so my thing
about the immigration we had that debate
earlier I hate all the incendiary
language I think it's repellent I think
Bradman in particular seems to
specialize I dream of flying them all
off to Rwanda these are in people
invading our country isn't just
non-poisonous but but isn't it Quentin
no it appears I would just urge this
caution uh if you try to suppress the
ordinary language that you hear on the
streets and say that we politicians talk
a different set of language I think you
then increase the gulf between
politicians but I don't agree with that
I'll tell you why because I actually
think when When leaders and Senior
politicians use inflammatory language it
whips up and encourages a lot more of it
in the street and actually the job of
politicians ought to be in my opinion to
use language which is not incendiary
they shouldn't be inflaming these they
can talk about the crisis that's here
clearly we have a massive problem in
trying to deal with this but they can do
it without using dehumanizing language I
disagree I think you get a disconnect
and I think that's where you get you you
get more attention Robert genre the
immigration Minister won't use the
language uh she is of information she
knows what she's doing she diverted
attention from our security breaches and
incompetence by getting getting this
argument around Innovation and it'll
incite some people but you're inciting
hate and we just saw with a far-right
terrorist fire bobbing 10 members of
parliament murdered in the last six
years of this country we've just seen
the U.S speaker's husband brutally
attacked by a lunatic who've been
whipped up to think Nancy Pelosi is the
devil you know I can see a real
connection between inflammatory retro
you saw it with Trump a lot you saw it
with Boris occasionally but Trump I
think worse when you use dehumanizing
language I don't think that helps any
part of democratic debate at all after
after uh Boris Johnson attacked women
wearing Burgers so they look like bank
robbers and post boxes there was a spike
in attacks on British Muslims look
politicians have to have a
responsibility in what they say I think
so and
they shouldn't be like people on the
street isn't that the point right now
you can have a connection in terms of
identifying a problem and saying I'm
going to solve it but actually using
incendiary language all that will do is
encourage everybody else to I think if
you create this impression that the
politicians are on a higher plane that
the politicians are a Clarity who uh who
take a higher view of things I think you
have a problem are we entitled are we
entitled to expect them to be on a
slightly higher plane given that they
are elected officials who want power to
serve over us entitled to expect a
better standard just let me answer I
think there's it's very important on an
issue like this where there has been
there is clearly a big difference
between what the the London political
class things and what you get elsewhere
in the country I think you have to to
knit back those two a lot more and the
language has become a bit Airy very okay
let me just switch on the topic this is
I'll be watching you know I have a thing
about the woke left just going
increasingly insane and actually in
doing so helping the right right and I
say that somebody probably slightly
Center left myself or I used to be
before the left got so mad that I now
look like I'm right
at home come on good morning Norway good
morning Norwich it's a god Morgan noggy
uh gmn so I have a particular Affinity
to a good morning Norway just add an
interview with the gerund Victoria Alma
53 who's an able-bodied male who now
identifies as a disabled woman this is
not a joke acquaintances actually I'm
I'm painting only a spot outrage on
social media because it appeared as a
disabled woman paralyzed from the waist
down because they'd always wished this
person to be a woman who was paralyzed
from the waist down Alma's a senior
credit analyst for a big Bank in Oslo
and has actually received positive
coverage in Norwegian media since
announcing trans disability publicly on
Facebook now
this self-identity thing has been going
increasingly nuts this is completely
insane
scores a lot of points on every sort of
register it's a double double tops for
being what disabled and trans and and
Norwegian Alma currently utilizes a
wheelchair almost all the time despite
having no physical handicap giving well
well if they want to get around in a
wheelchair then that's up to them but to
pretend can't identify as a disabled
woman no it's not no no you shouldn't
and I think so it's too woke even for
you
finally finally cracked Maguire
I'm all for respect and being sensible
and pragmatic now disabled people will
probably be cheesed off should we say
but this is what happens
when you allow Limitless self-identity
it's quite clever to find a new a new
Niche yes
nobody else is sort of this this
shouldn't be used as a broad attack on
trans what about people or anybody else
I think when when this kind of stuff
happens it makes a mockery of the whole
thing like we said something probably a
little bit more serious director James
Gray defending his latest film
Armageddon time because he's cast Anne
Hathaway Anthony Hopkins and Jeremy
Strong as a real-life Jewish immigrant
family even though they're not Jewish
including Anthony Hopkins
let me think of this I mean I again have
a problem with this Quentin I think
you're right I have a problem that I to
me actors
that's the whole point yes they don't
all you don't have to have Irish people
playing Irish people they're going to
have disabled people playing disabled
people gay people play we've never had
to do this before nobody's minded why
suddenly are we obsessed that everybody
who plays a character in a film or TV
show has to be that because people are
running scared of Twitter and social
media and they're being stampeded by a
few Nutters and I think they should be
stood up to but they're I'm afraid it
seems to be going that way and we'll
never again will you have someone like
Kenneth Moore playing Douglas beta
because he's got to have some an actor
who's got no legs Tom Hanks in
Philadelphia yeah brilliant Sean a
massive light on AIDS and probably did
enormous help are you going to do that
with somebody who you've never heard of
who might have Aids in real life who
plays it purely to take a box I I have
an autistic uh uh we have autism in the
family and one of the most important
films for me personally was Rain Man yes
Dustin Hoffman yeah autistic who wasn't
a force autistic
amazing because he's a brilliant actor
Redmond and Benedict Cumberbatch both
played Stephen Hawking yeah is it Helen
Mirren is going to play Golden mayor the
Israeli
um
yeah I think it only becomes an issue
right and um I'm kind of agreeing with
you but it only comes an issue where
underrepresented groups if they're there
on getting getting roles if gay actors
feel that they're not or disabled back I
think my point I know I know everybody
everybody should have the same
opportunity yeah right so it's like all
these things same opportunity football
right everyone if you're a disabled
person if you're gay if you're trans if
you're black if you're white whatever
you just should be given the same
opportunity and where that opportunity
is thwarted through a system then change
the system to make it more inclusive but
that doesn't mean you then have to cast
every single specific role yeah the
disconnect again yeah between the elite
and the people yes I agree and the even
the language that is discussed that is
used to discuss these things is just
it's a Minefield it is on which I
repeatedly stand
do all actors get equal opportunity
because there are fewer roles say for
women because of the way uh so many
films and TV shows yeah the answer that
they're now doing they want gender
neutral award shows and all that will
mean in the end probably women win less
Awards I don't know because they were
broadly well it's like the Olympics all
right you have the Olympics you're
making gender neutral oh no then you'll
find no women yeah win a gold medal
Norwegians no but this guy would win
yeah
in acting and in in music it doesn't
mean fewer women all right sport wood
where it's just unequal let me just
before I let you go how do you pronounce
Adele
like no Adele you just said It Adele
right let's listen to Adele today Adele
from Enfield was having I love that she
said my name perfectly came and asked me
how I say my name and I was like Adele
hello
Adele Adele Adele no you see it's
actually Adele she just can't pronounce
it because she's from Tottenham and
she's a Tottenham fan and she pronounces
her own name wrong she was christened
Adele but she wants us to think it's
Adele Adele because Adele we'll have you
on EastEnders because she's a Spurs fan
and you can't I don't think that's right
she should have been a re-categorize her
name was she the the singer probably
known as Adele
good to see you um I appreciate you
coming in well next to that sporting
Legend Gareth Thomas the first openly
gave Rugby Union star which Wants To Be
Live to discuss protests against the
Qatar World Cup
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to Facebook nonsense to
build up to a World Cup that's normally
dominated by frenzied excitement and
optimism this year is just a lot of
negativity it's getting ever more
deafening it's a growing chorus of
critics rail against host nation guitars
non-existent LGBT rights and the way
they've been treating migrant workers
but is it time for the protest to stop
and for players who don't agree with any
of that to put out of the tournament uh
or just stay and focus on the football
we're joining me now is former Welsh
rugby player Garrett Thomas and comedian
Ronald Cameron welcome to both of you
Gareth you are a World Cup Legend you
played in four World Cups I just got
told which is pretty extraordinary
um what do you think of this it's it's
complicated because I think I would
probably imagine we all agree about a
few things one Qatar should never have
been awarded this in the first place
given the apparent corruption that was
going on they then reconfigured all the
schedules to play it in the best you
know heat that they can provide but that
ruins a lot of the domestic schedules
like our own here and so on and
obviously there are lots of Human Rights
uh incidents as well that we should be
taking into consideration however the
Middle East has never had the World Cup
it's a huge football loving region of
the world is it not the time now as we
get towards the tournament after 12
years of knowing it's going to be here
to say you know what let's just get on
with the football
so I I think I think on the point of 12
years of knowing like I myself and so
many other people have been trying to
raise awareness and when you talk about
you know I I follow you and I like you
and and as I go see a virtue signaling
if anything the the media are now guilty
of that because all of a sudden the
World Cup has become something that has
got attention so all of a sudden there's
focused attention on the World Cup oh
but we can't just focus attention on the
World Cup we now have to focus on this
but I and so many other organizations
have been trying to kind of raise the
fact that the human rights and the laws
anti-gay people live in there or being
born or being able to survive there have
been you know I've been around for such
such a long time here's the problem
I completely support gay rights to
equality full period end and obviously I
hate the fact that in Qatar it's it's
different but eight of the 32 teams left
in this world cup are countries where
it's illegal to be gay it's not just
guitar and then when you look at the
other countries involved in the World
Cup almost all of them have huge human
rights issues including by the way if
you look at our own country you know
we're illegally invaded Iraq waiting two
decades of terrorism in other words if
you put the morality argument up where
does it end where do you end up being
able to place four
can I because I think you can't blame
the individuals who are playing the
sport you can't blame the individuals
who are playing the sport for what for
what their country is kind of
representing you kind of go there as a
team with your with your own
representation in your own wants and
your own fans and I think that's where
the players become important and the the
message all of a sudden becomes
important I agree let me bring it on the
signaling of people wearing armbands
yeah yeah I mean I my thing about the
armbands is it's like well so what it's
not going to make any difference Rona
what's your view about this
well firstly I'm glad there was a break
between the Norwegian and disabled
identifying as a woman item because I
nearly I lost control of my father
so I was worrying that we were going to
come to us straight after that so yeah
there is a lot of insanity in the world
and human beings are feeling the
pressure everywhere in terms of this
tournament I mean of course it should
never have been there in the first place
and FIFA
um are going to make something like 5
billion uh pounds out of this tournament
whilst these uh you know as you've said
these poor workers from the Philippines
and Nepal and all the rest of it I've
been working 10 hour days in 40 degree
heat I mean if you just think about
those those things that basic sort of
information it's absolutely shocking and
then we're dealing with the fact that
um along with several other countries
largely with with the Sharia law there's
still the debt penalty for homosexuals
and you're quite right there there is
there is some double standards with
other countries in the world I mean
let's let's remind everyone that in the
UK it was the late 80s before they
stopped seeing homosexuality as a
mentors we're running out of time I
think I would simply say I think the
problem with getting a moral Halo on
about sport is you end up not being at a
play anywhere because everyone's got
their problems but it's a good debate
thank you for joining me we're gonna
have a longer debate about this I've got
to leave it there to Gareth Arona thank
you whatever you're up to Keep It
Uncensored good night
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign